[Music]
this morning we're showing you a
neighborhood in Detroit that just
refuses to be forgotten it fell victim
to economic hardship and urban decay
decades ago and most residents just
moved away but one man one guy saw
beauty and what was left behind
now his artwork attracts hundreds of
thousands of visitors every year
Adriana Diaz takes us on a stroll down
Heidelberg Street good morning let me
give you a little tour here we have a
pile of suitcases an old classroom chair
a baseball mitt and a mountain of shoes
what once was discarded trash has been
repurposed and reimagined as art it's
all the life's work of a man who grew up
on this block and turned a once
abandoned Detroit neighborhood into a
tourist destination if a junkyard had a
fever dream it might look something like
this
[Music]
scattered and empty lots among the few
remaining homes on this two block
stretch of Heidelberg Street are
seemingly random objects that might make
more sense inside those homes but making
sense seems to be the last thing on the
mind of artist Tyree guiding people
probably will come here I think it looks
like a junkyard yes yeah and that's okay
with you that's okay Guyton grew up on
this street with three generations of
his family through the rise and fall and
now Renaissance of the city around it
Detroit my grandfather he was my best
friend I was nine years of age when he
gave me a paintbrush and told me to
paint and said that the world was my
canvas at that world imploded in 1967
when racial tensions and post-war urban
decline sparked five days of deadly
riots in their own backyard
oh I thought the world was coming to an
end and then terribly it was hit hard so
the riots and the aftermath led to the
emptying out of this neighborhood
absolutely that's really driven you oh
yes to bring people bring the focus back
someone had to do it so why not me I can
see the ghosts of the people used to
live here when those people moved out
they left behind the objects that once
filled their lives so I decided to
gather those things up and to create
this magic so you're making a statement
yeah the things that are left behind
we're still valuable absolutely you make
it valuable valuable because today
Guyton so-called Heidelberg project
attracts an estimated 200,000 visitors a
year from all over the world adding more
than three million dollars annually to
the local economy I just like the oddity
of it on this is a great way to put this
area on the map bringing the
neighborhood back to the neighborhood
it's really interesting it also brought
controversy to the neighborhood some
residents complained about traffic and
code violations and the city even
bulldozed parts of it twice
I don't mind getting in trouble first
and apologizing later if necessary the
Heidelberg project is now working with
the city to address those concerns a
task that falls to its president
Janine Whitfield it's like any other
family you got sisters and brothers they
go don't get along but we never stop
trying a former banker she made a wrong
turn down Heidelberg Street 26 years ago
and met Gaytan sitting on the curb today
she's also his wife do you feel that
your work has followed the rise and fall
and rise of Detroit I definitely do I
think it is the greatest symbol and as
the city of Detroit is kind of having
this new light so to speak so it's the
Heidelberg project ironically that new
life means dismantling some of the
installations and moving them to
galleries around the world they have a
proposal at City Hall to turn this once
blighted neighborhood into a vibrant
artists village with live work studios
in Arts Academy and businesses that
cater to them they've even trademarked
to their own school of art we call it
Heidelberg ology what is your definition
of Heidelberg ology it is the study of
found materials incorporated into the
fabric and structure of an urban
community and the effects on that
community
you put Heidelberg this neighborhood on
the map and now you want to take it to
the next level that's why I can walk
away I've done it as this neighborhoods
profiles risen so has guidance he's now
represented by an art gallery in New
York and other cities have asked him to
create works of art to revitalize their
neighborhoods so it seems the philosophy
of Heidelberg ology is spreading I'll
say thank you Adriana it just shows you
because at first it does look kind of
junky but it shows you the beauty of the
ordinary when you look at the stories
behind what we're looking at yeah I
appreciate all relate to that I
appreciate his motto of act first and
apologize later I hope it doesn't leave
to an artist community there cuz that's
a really great legacy nicely done very
nicely